PRESENTER: Good
afternoon, and welcome
to Talks at Google in
Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Today, it's my
privilege to introduce
two extraordinary individuals--
Professor Lani Guinier and Dr.
Debra Bial.
Among many other things,
both are fierce advocates
of equal educational
opportunity for all.
Deborah Bial was
MacArthur Fellow in 2007.
She is an education
strategist who
addresses the
challenges of college
access for under-represented
populations
by identifying and fostering
latent talent and opening
opportunities for them to
pursue higher education.
Through her Posse
Foundation, which
is funded in part by Google,
she offers an alternative model
for identifying promising young
people from less advantaged
urban environments.
Promising students are invited
to join a Posse-- a small group
that participates in an
eight-month pre-collegiate
training program that builds
individual and team skills
and serves as an essential
social support system
once students arrive at college.
She served as the founder
and president of the Posse
Foundation since 1989.
She's also a founding partner of
the consulting company Firefly
Education, LLC.
Lani Guinier is the
first woman of color
appointed to a tenured
professorship at Harvard Law
School.
Previously, she had
been a tenured professor
at the University
of Pennsylvania,
a lawyer with the NAACP
Legal Defense Fund,
Special Assistant to the
Assistant Attorney General
for Civil Rights during
the Carter Administration,
and was nominated
by President Clinton
to be the first black woman to
head the Civil Rights Division
of the Department of Justice.
Professor Guinier, on behalf
of the people of United States,
I apologize for how
that went-- sincerely.
She is the author of
several books, most recently
"The Tyranny of the Meritocracy:
Democratizing Higher
Education in America."
And she has received
10 honorary degrees,
although I suspect that
she feels equally honored
to have received awards
for teaching excellence
from both Penn and
Harvard Law Schools.
Please join me in welcoming
in conversation Lani
Guinier and Deborah Bial.
[APPLAUSE]
DEBORAH BIAL: We're just
winging this, you guys.
But-- not really.
We're acting like we are.
I'm Debbie Bial.
I run the Posse Foundation.
LANI GUINIER: I'm
Lani Guinier, and I'm
a law professor who is very
fond of the Posse Foundation.
DEBORAH BIAL: We're
fond of each other.
We really are, actually.
I admire Lani enormously.
And this is the first time that
we've actually come together
to talk about an issue
that we've been dealing
with separately for decades.
And what I am so
grateful to Lani for
is that she has written
extensively about an issue
that this country doesn't
talk enough about.
And that is the idea that
the country was built on,
which is that we're supposed
to be a meritocracy.
And I work with 52 different
colleges and universities,
all elite.
And those institutions
are really
gatekeepers for
young people who want
to achieve the American dream.
And Lani has written
a lot about that.
And you validate
what we do at Posse.
And I'll talk more about that,
but I wanted to thank you,
because it's an
honor to be here.
LANI GUINIER: Oh, wow.
DEBORAH BIAL: Thank you.
LANI GUINIER: Well, I'll just
be quiet, and I'll let you talk.
No, it's a privilege to be here.
I've had a lot of opportunity
to talk to and work
with one of the former Posse
officers, Shirley Collado.
DEBORAH BIAL: Right.
And she was a Posse member.
LANI GUINIER: Right.
And she's the one who really
explained to me what it
was like to be a Posse member.
And her story is so
powerful, because she's
the daughter of
a taxi driver who
was somebody who had
come to the United States
from another country.
And her father was
extremely worried
that she was going to leave New
York City to go to Vanderbilt,
which is in Tennessee.
And so they arranged
an agreement
that she would call him or
he would call her every day--
he's a taxi driver-- at
9 o'clock or 8 o'clock,
and she'd have to report to
him as to what she was doing.
And it turned out,
initially, that she
thought this was intrusive.
But it turned out to be very
powerful in a way of reassuring
her, because she was
in a new environment
completely without coming in
with old friends or people
who've been there before.
And so the fact that
she had somebody
to look forward to to
talk to every night
was very affirming for her.
She ended up doing
extraordinarily well.
She ended up getting a PhD.
She's now-- I'm not sure exactly
of her position at Rutgers,
but she's in a high--
DEBORAH BIAL: Executive
Vice Chancellor.
LANI GUINIER: OK.
Executive Vice
Chancellor, who used
to rely on to her
taxicab father to move
on to the next day of her life.
So she's just a really good
example of the Posse program.
DEBORAH BIAL: But what
Lani writes-- you guys
should all read her
book, which we have.
Make the pitch at the beginning,
the middle, and the end.
But Lani has a whole chapter
dedicated to this program
as an example of how we
can be thinking differently
about defining
this term "merit."
And I like to talk
about the word "merit"
because-- I don't know
how many of you went
to one of what we call the
most selective colleges
in the United
States, but there's
over 1,400 four-year colleges
in the United States.
If you took just the top
10%, the ones that everyone
has heard of-- the
Ivy League schools,
and Vanderbilt, Northwestern,
and Duke, these kinds
of schools,
Middlebury-- they still
rely pretty heavily on the
SAT as a way of deciding
who's going to be admitted.
You're familiar.
You know this idea.
But in 2015, it's still
white and Asian kids
that are scoring the
best on those tests.
Now, we could talk
about all the problems
and why that is the case.
But here's a kid like
Shirley-- and I just
want to jump on your story a
little bit-- Shirley grew up
in Brooklyn.
She's a Dominican
kid who got 800
combined-- I'm letting this
sink in-- combined on the math
and reading sections of the SAT.
She lets us say this-- combined.
She never in a
million years would've
gotten into Vanderbilt.
We get her into Vanderbilt.
She graduates with honors.
She gets her doctorate in
clinical psychology from Duke.
She becomes the dean of
the college at Middlebury.
And within the
next five years, I
think she's going to
be a college president.
Today, those schools
that I mentioned,
88% of the presidents of
those schools are white men.
If you look at who's in the
US Senate, 94% of our Senate
is white.
Most are men.
The same thing with who runs
Fortune 500 companies-- white
guys, mostly.
And their Section 16
executives, white.
So what we're talking
about is, well,
how do we keep going like that?
Right, Lani?
Because if we keep
doing that in a country
where the demographics are
changing radically-- and what,
within the next 30 years, white
Hispanics will be the minority,
no longer be the majority.
We're not going to
have a country that's
representative of its people.
So maybe we could
talk a little bit
about why it's important
for the elite schools--
why do you think, and why
do I-- why should they
be focused on thinking
differently about who deserves
to be on their campuses?
LANI GUINIER: So
just to put what
you're saying into a
slightly larger context--
and I definitely
want to follow up
what you're saying-- the
book that I am describing--
or that actually, you've done
a great job of describing--
is really about what
we mean by merit.
And so it's a larger question
than just who is benefiting
from the concept of merit.
But we tend to think
of merit as something
that measures how well you
do on a particular test
at a particular moment.
And what I am trying
to do in this book,
and what I think is
consistent with what the Posse
program does, is to give people
another way of identifying
with and exhibiting merit.
And that is working
together in groups,
in posses, that can
look at a problem
from different perspectives,
and as a result,
work together to
solve that problem.
And adding to your comment
about the number of men
versus women-- and finding more
women who are going to college
and who are graduating,
because it turns out
that the women are better at
collaborating with each other
then the men.
There's a study by a woman named
Anita Woolley who, in fact, I
think was working with
MIT at the same time she
was doing this study.
And what they were
trying to find out
is who was leading
the conversation
and what groups were
most effective in solving
the particular
problems that were
presented before the groups.
And it turned out that the more
women you had in the group,
the better the group was at
solving the problem, up to 85%.
Once you had 85% women, it
was fine to bring in the men.
They would not be a
complete distraction.
OK.
Now, why would that be if
we have so few women who
are in positions
of power, and yet
those are the
people who are most
likely to work together to
collaborate to solve problems?
And I don't know the
answer to the question
of why is this true
of women and not men.
It may be biological.
It may be cultural.
There are all kinds
of explanations.
But it's really important
that we acknowledge
the value and the, quote,
"merit" of people--
disproportionately women--
who can work together
to solve problems.
And the reason they can work
together to solve problems
is that they're willing
to listen to each other.
Whereas what many of the men
do is that they immediately
think of an answer
and want to say
the answer to everyone else.
They're not really interested
in what other people are saying.
They're self-promoting-- not
all men, but many of them.
And so the point
I'm trying to make,
the point I'm emphasizing,
is the power of collaboration
and the importance in the
21st century of developing
a group of college graduates
who are comfortable working
with other people to
solve complicated problems
and who are not simply trying
to dominate the conversation
and demonstrate how smart
they individually are,
but who are willing to listen
to what other people are saying,
build on what those
other people are saying,
and create new and helpful
instruments for solving
these problems.
One last example is a professor
from the University of Michigan
who also is doing
work on groups.
And his experience
is with people who
are all taking the same test.
And his argument is that
when you give people a test
and there are 10
questions on the test,
there are some
people who are going
to immediately answer
7 of the 10 questions
and get them right.
But they don't get all
of the questions right.
So what do they do?
Our instinct is to get the
people who had the 7 of the 10
questions right, because they
had the most questions right,
and we put all of them together.
That's the SAT idea.
You get the people who all
did, quote, "the best."
But what if it turns
out that you're
overlooking two or
three of the answers
to questions that these, quote
unquote, "stars" got wrong,
and that some people got those
three or two questions right,
but didn't get as many questions
right as the initial group
leaders?
You really want people
to work together,
even though they only got
2 or 3 of the 10 questions
right, if it turns out that
they're the only ones who
got those correct.
So the idea is
that-- and I think
it's very similar
and very compatible
with the concept of Posse--
is that in the 21st century,
it's really important that
you can work in groups.
And I don't mean work in groups,
and we all march together,
and you follow everyone.
I mean work in a position
where you are not
the only person with ideas.
You are open to
other people's ideas,
and you're willing to
test out their ideas
and see ways in which
those ideas can be improved
or can be--
DEBORAH BIAL:
That's very Google.
LANI GUINIER: Very Google?
DEBORAH BIAL: But
Lani, can I ask what--
since I have you
captive-- why do
you think we've been so
resistant to this when we admit
people to these colleges?
Why are we clinging
to the SAT so much?
LANI GUINIER: Well,
first of all, there's
a lot of money behind
the SAT and those tests.
So there's a part
of the population
that's invested in that in
terms of their livelihood.
I think the idea that you can
reduce people's intelligence
and you can reduce people's
ability to the performance--
DEBORAH BIAL: Test scores.
LANI GUINIER: Yeah.
On a single test.
It's not like you get the chance
to do this test every month
for a year.
DEBORAH BIAL: Raise your hand
if you took the SAT or the ACT.
Look how many--
almost all of you.
Raise your hand if
you went to college.
And raise your hand
if someone said
to you, what was your score.
Do you remember that?
And raise your hand if you're
willing to tell us your score
right now.
Exactly.
A couple.
A lot less hands.
Because we still feel
like it reflects--
there's a judgment
that we're going
to make about you if
we hear your score.
That's terrible.
We shouldn't make that
judgment about you right now.
And look how old you are.
I'm sorry.
LANI GUINIER: Can I just hang a
footnote to what you're saying,
and then you can proceed?
DEBORAH BIAL: Yes.
LANI GUINIER: So I
have to tell you--
it's a personal story-- when
I was admitted to Radcliffe
College of Harvard University.
DEBORAH BIAL: This is a
good story in your end--
I love the story.
LANI GUINIER: So
my father, who was
born in Jamaica in
the West Indies,
he came to United States.
He went to Boston
English High School.
He then applied to Harvard.
He was admitted to
Harvard College,
except that they didn't
realize he was black.
They didn't have that kind
of photography or whatever.
DEBORAH BIAL: No photo included.
LANI GUINIER: And that was
his "mistake," quote unquote,
because he showed up.
And once they saw him,
they said, oh my god,
what are we going
to do with you?
So they admitted him, since
they had already admitted him.
But they wouldn't allow
to live in the dormitory.
They wouldn't allow him
to eat in the dining halls
with the other students.
And the first person to-- well,
there are a number of people.
But the people he knew from
Boston English High School,
where he had been the
chair of the newspaper
and had done very well,
and who were his friends,
those people were very
friendly when he was
at Boston English High School.
But once he was at
Harvard College,
they wouldn't talk
to him, either.
So I'm saying that
because for me, he
felt it was important
that I go to Harvard,
test it out, see if they've
improved in the past 40 years.
But it was also
in many ways what
I felt was a painful
experience-- that
is, my roommate-- I
believe that's what
you were talking about.
So my roommate comes
into my dorm room
the first day of
class, and she starts
telling me about herself.
And she explained that she
was very worried that she
would never get married.
And I'm thinking, this is
a very odd conversation.
This is the first
day of college.
I'm 17 years old.
I'm definitely not thinking
about who I might marry.
But she was using
this as an opportunity
to brag about her test
scores, because it
turns that she had gotten
perfect 800s on her SATs.
So that was her
announcement to me,
and I was there for-- I
should be observant of her
and learn from her.
And what I learned was to
move to another dorm room.
DEBORAH BIAL: But
what she means,
and what other people
would be really impressed,
is that she is smart.
We equate that test
score with intelligence.
And when we use the word
"merit" in higher ed,
and we give out
merit scholarships,
we give them to the kids
with the highest test scores,
because if you look the word
"merit" up in the dictionary,
it means deserve.
Who deserves to be at Harvard?
Who deserves to be at Cornell?
Who deserves to
be at Vanderbilt?
The kids with the
highest scores,
because they are the smartest.
It's that simple.
But because white and Asian
kids are still scoring the best,
they deserve to be
at these schools
more than black and Asian
kids, than poor kids who
don't score as well.
There's an amazing stat.
I know you're going
to love this stat.
The top 150 schools
in the United States
would need 50,000 black
students every year
going into their freshman
class, their first-year class,
if they were going to reflect
the percentage of blacks
that exist in the
American population.
But only 9,000 black
kids scored 1,200
or above on the math and verbal
sections of the SAT last year.
LANI GUINIER: 9,000 in
the in entire country?
DEBORAH BIAL: In the
entire United States.
If we continue to rely
too heavily on the SAT,
we'll never get the kind
of reflective diversity
that we want on our campuses.
And if we continue to
define merit so narrowly
that it only relates
to the test score,
we're basically going
to say a certain slice
of the demographic deserves
to be on our campuses.
The others, we'll create
charity programs for.
At risk, poor kids,
under-represented, needy,
underprivileged-- we've
got programs for them.
And when you do that,
you divide the community.
You create a campus
community that says,
these kids deserve to be here.
And then out of the
kindness of our hearts,
we're bringing in
the rest of you.
And that's very dangerous
for this country.
Kids with high scores, of
course, deserve, of course.
But they're not the
only kids that deserve.
And so I feel like what we have
an opportunity to do together
is say, here's the theory
and the analysis behind it,
and here's one example of a
program that puts into practice
this other way of
finding talent.
And think about how--
Google is a company that
thinks outside the box.
You're all about that.
You need people who are creative
thinkers who think differently.
And you want to put
teams together--
don't you guys believe in
working in teams a lot,
or is that just
what I'm imagining?
You do, right?
The teams are more fun.
They're more dynamic.
They're sillier.
But you come up with
great ideas that way,
where if you're working
by yourself only,
if it would happen in a
different way, less often.
So Posse says-- there was a
kid who dropped out of college.
He said, I never
would have dropped out
if I have my posse with me.
This kid was super
smart-- great SAT scores,
by the way-- got
into an Ivy League,
but dropped out because
of the culture shock,
because he didn't
see anybody like him.
The posse created
a support system.
But then we began to look
at these other indicators.
And I bet if anybody--
is anyone here
responsible for hiring people?
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Brian.
DEBORAH BIAL: Ryan?
AUDIENCE: Brian
DEBORAH BIAL: Brian,
so you don't only
care about a test score now.
You look for other things.
You look for grit.
You look for leadership ability.
You look for analytical
ability, problem solving skills,
ability to work well in
a team, collaborate--
I can go on and on.
Aren't you looking
for all those things?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DEBORAH BIAL: Among--
I'm not saying--
when these kids
are 17 years old,
they're nominated to Posse.
I wish I could stand up.
I always want to stand up.
We can put them in a room like--
LANI GUINIER: You can stand up.
DEBORAH BIAL: No, because the
camera and the whole thing.
But imagine a room like
this with no furniture.
And 100 kids from Boston
come into this room.
They've been nominated by
someone who believes in them.
And the person who
believes in them
says, this kid might not have
the best score, but I know her.
She's amazing.
She could kick ass at
a school like Union.
They walk in, and for
three hours-- and Brian,
I think you would
love this if we did it
at Google-- those
100 kids get put
through a series of activities.
They're building
robots out of LEGOs.
They're running a
discussion in small groups
on genetic testing.
Quick, you have four
minutes, run a discussion.
They are creating a public
service announcement
that they have to
present in front of you.
And we're watching
them and looking
for these-- I don't
like this term,
but people call non-cognitive
traits-- they're cognitive.
Anyway, we find the standout
kids, the dynamic kids,
the kids who think
creatively, the kids
who work well in teams,
the kids who are leaders,
who have ambition and drive
and motivation and all of that.
That's our first
slice of the pie.
We don't even look at
the test score yet.
We'll look at that later.
That's one way of finding
talent, kids who are amazing,
kids who deserve to have a
shot at the American dream.
And so we're putting
into practice
this idea that you shouldn't
define merit so narrowly.
LANI GUINIER: I think
that's a great example.
I'm also thinking of
some of the TV shows
where you can see black kids
walking across the terrain
in front of the projects.
And in one of these shows,
there were two brothers
who were talking about
the amount of marijuana
that they had each sold
that particular day
and how much money
they had made.
And the younger one was
computing in his head
how much he had
sold and how much
he had benefited from the sale.
And his older brother
was just amazed,
because the younger
brother, who was
in the fourth grade
or fifth grade
was not doing well
in math, and yet he's
doing this in his head.
And so the older brother says,
how come you're failing math?
And he said, because
I don't really
care what the
outcome is in math,
but I care in terms of
selling these drugs.
If I get it wrong,
they're going to kill me.
So there's a talent
there, but it's not being
developed in the right format.
DEBORAH BIAL: So we have a
few more minutes to talk,
and then we're going to
open it up for questions.
And I thought
maybe it would also
be interesting to
hear a little bit more
about how you think these higher
ed institutions can change,
what you think they can do.
LANI GUINIER: Well, this is
an opportunity for me to cry,
because I've been trying
to get institutions
where I teach to
at least address--
they don't necessarily have
to cure-- but at least address
the issues that we've
been discussing.
Now, I've been at law schools,
not at elementary schools
or at, quote
unquote, "colleges."
But what I did find-- and
this is not about class
as much as it is about gender--
the people at both law schools
that I was associated or
have been associated with,
both at UPenn and
at Harvard, there
are more men than
women in the school.
The men outperform the women,
although the women come
into the school with
very similar criteria
as the men in terms
of their LSAT scores
and their undergraduate GPA.
In fact, the women have slightly
higher undergraduate GPA
and have slightly
higher LSAT scores,
but they're statistically
not significant.
And yet the women, when
they come to law school--
these are considered important
and difficult-to-get-into law
schools-- the women have
the LSAT scores that would
presumably predict that they're
going to do better in law
school, but they don't do as
well as the men in law school.
So the LSAT is predicting
about 14% of the variance
in first-year classes--
this was at Penn--
and 15% of the variance
in second year, which
means that 85% of the
time, the LSAT was wrong.
Wrong, W-R-O-N-G.
DEBORAH BIAL: So
what's going on then?
LANI GUINIER: The LSAT
is not a good predictor.
It tells you how
well somebody is
at answering certain questions
under a lot of stress,
but that doesn't mean you're
going to be a good lawyer.
And it doesn't mean you're
going to be a good law
student either.
So if 85% of the time
you are wrong in terms
of the correlation
between your LSAT scores
and your performance,
we need to reconsider
what we're considering,
quote unquote, "merit."
DEBORAH BIAL: So
what should they do?
If you could press
the button and Harvard
and Yale and Princeton would
change, how would they change?
LANI GUINIER: Well,
the answer to that
is a long one, because they'd
have to change the culture.
It's not enough just
to change the score,
because you could
say, oh, well they
could say if you pass
the LSAT, that's enough.
You don't have to
have a higher LSAT,
since the distinction
in your LSAT score
really is not very predictive.
So the LSAT could be a floor.
That is, you have to
get above that floor.
Even if you're right
above it, that's fine.
We're not going to
compare you to people
who are doing a lot better,
because I could show you
scatter plots, et cetera
where you see people
who had really high LSAT scores
and really low law school
grades.
DEBORAH BIAL: And
my guess, Lani,
is that people listening to
you-- I have this sense--
know or are wondering if
maybe those scores would
be more predictive if
culture was different
on these campuses, that as
a woman, I get a high score
and I go to Harvard, but because
the culture is a certain way,
my performance is affected.
I don't know.
LANI GUINIER: But this
is true for men and women
in terms of the LSAT being a
good predictor of performance.
So becoming a man is not
going to help you in terms
of doing better at law schools.
But what I really
wanted to get back to,
which is what Posse
is well known for,
is the power of working
with other people,
collaborating and building trust
among that group of people,
each of whom is
bringing something new,
something different,
something potentially
important to the group.
And so the challenge is,
are you in a position
to take advantage of what the
various people in this room
or in a particular
group have to offer?
Or are you one of
these people who
has to dominate
the conversation,
has to show how smart
you are, and has
to take charge in
which you are leading
and everyone is just following?
That can be very boring and
also not very effective.
Whereas if we had a culture
shift-- not just a rule
shift-- meaning a culture
shift that says the way
we think merit-- and Amartya
Sen has a definition of merit.
Merit is an incentive
system that rewards actions
a society values, an
incentive system that rewards
actions a society values.
Well, maybe the
actions that we value
are not how well
you do on the test,
but how well you do in solving
the real problems of the world.
And you alone are not going
to be able to do that.
But if you find the
right posse, you
find the right group
of people, each of whom
has something to
offer, then you're
in a position to start really
solving difficult problems.
And it's not that you alone
are going to solve them.
And it may not be that even
the group you're part of alone
is going to solve the problem.
But you're introducing
interventions
that invite and excite
other people who
then build on what you've done.
And through that
process, I think,
we'll be in much better shape.
By contrast, what
we have right now,
at least in college admission
and college graduation,
is competition as to who is--
DEBORAH BIAL: Does the best.
LANI GUINIER: --who's
doing the best.
That is, whose school is
admitting the students
with the highest LSAT scores?
And then whose schools are
graduating the people who
go and make the most money?
And then the idea of the
contribution to society,
the commitment to democracy,
the commitment to making sure
that as a democracy,
we want to make
sure everybody, as many
people as possible,
are educated, because
we never know,
among those people, who is going
to really contribute something
unique, and something
that's brave,
and something that really works.
We don't have a good
predictor of that outcome
through the LSAT, the SAT,
the GRE, none of those.
What those tests tend to
tell us is what kind of car
your parents drive, meaning
they have enough money
to buy a Mercedes,
so you've obviously
been able to do
well on this test,
because they've
also bought people
who are going to help you to
get prepared for the test.
And then, of course, when you're
writing out your admissions
data, you also get somebody
else who writes it for you.
Right?
They're working on your
behalf, presumably.
But they're not going to be
there when you're in college
and you have an exam
or something else
to do that you're
really not prepared for,
because the way you got
there was somebody else was
pushing you or functioning as
a pedestal on which you could
stand.
So I'm saying all this because I
think that the Posse program is
wonderful, not just because
it's bringing together students
from working class families,
but because it's also giving us
the opportunity to see how
teams can be created and built
in ways that not only give
people who are part of the team
confidence, but give
the people who benefit
from the outcome of
the work of the team
some sense that life is
better with the interventions.
DEBORAH BIAL: I'm going to use
those as a quote in our next--
that's good.
Good.
So should we turn to you guys?
Because you have a million
questions, I'm sure.
LANI GUINIER: I
hope not a million.
DEBORAH BIAL: We'll
start at the beginning.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So it sounds like the
population that you're
most concerned with are
the students that are
both minorities and talented.
And I guess I have-- my brother
is now applying to colleges.
He's just deciding
where he's going.
So I've been hearing a
lot about this lately.
And I have questions about
the population who is either
talented but not
diverse, not minority,
and the population that
is maybe not so talented.
So I guess my two
situations that I've
seen that are concerning-- one
is, say, a friend of mine who's
a white guy in engineering,
really smart, and is really
struggling to get
into schools, and he
feels like there are a lot
of spots that are reserved
for people of other categories.
He's a really smart
white guy, and is really
struggling to get
noticed, because he
doesn't have anything special.
In this particular
case, yes, his parents
went to college-- community
college, not really
super academic kind of people.
He wasn't from a
Mercedes-driving kind
of family, didn't really get
the support and the motivation
and everything.
But he feels like
because he's white,
it doesn't really
count for anything.
So that's the one situation
of talented but not minority.
And the other
situation that I see
are people who are really
not interested in pursuing
academic careers.
I actually was a serious ballet
dancer, and a lot of my friends
didn't go to college, because if
you want to be a ballet dancer,
why would you spend $150,000
on a college education?
It doesn't make any sense.
DEBORAH BIAL: Or more.
AUDIENCE: More, yeah.
So what about for
those people who--
or they want to
pursue culinary arts,
or they want to do whatever else
that doesn't depend on getting
a college education, where
they feel like they're being
pressured to spend a
fortune and go into debt
to get an education
that maybe they
could have an excellent
professional career doing
the things that they want
with another path that somehow
is looked down upon?
So I guess what are your
thoughts on people in those two
situations?
LANI GUINIER: OK.
So first, I think you
should go to Canada--
you don't have to stay,
just visit-- and see
the way in which they admit
people to their schools.
If you have a grade point
average of over 80%,
you're automatically admitted
to one of their colleges.
And I don't know that you're
entitled to your first choice,
but they try and
give you at least one
of your first three choices.
And I don't believe
college is free,
but it's not very expensive.
So that would solve
a lot of the problems
that you're talking about.
The other point that you're
making, though, I think
is really important.
And that is that people
are coming to college,
and they're really
not there to learn.
They're there to promote
themselves into another sphere
where they will be
making a lot of money.
So for example, in "The
Harvard Crimson" of about five
or so years ago,
they had an article
called "Show Him The Money."
That was the front page
of "The Harvard Crimson."
That's the newspaper
the students publish.
And what they were
commenting on-- they'd
done a survey of the
graduating class.
This was in May of that year.
And the survey noted
that the men from Harvard
wanted to go to Wall
Street, because they
wanted to make a lot of money.
And the women wanted to become
lawyers or doctors or teachers.
And the people who are
writing this article
were making fun of the
women, the women who
wanted to do good,
because they should have
been trying to get the money.
And it suggests
that-- that's why
I say you need a culture shift.
It's not just that you have
a certain group of people
and not another group of people.
It's that the culture
of higher education
has lost some of its connection
to promoting democracy
and the importance
of civic involvement
that is the basis of many of
the colleges in this country.
It's the reason that
they were created.
And yet they've been shifted
from an engine of democracy
to an engine of plutocracy.
DEBORAH BIAL: And Lani, can
you help me answer this also?
I have an idea formulated.
Because behind
what you're saying
is a question that I've
heard a lot of times
from white people whose kids
are applying to college,
and they're worried
that the black kid is
going to take the spot
that their kid should get.
And I'm not saying this is
your question, but I hear it.
And I hear that question a lot.
There's a black kid in
my daughter's school,
and she didn't score as well
as my daughter did on the SAT.
And I know she's going
to get in to x school.
And my daughter deserves
to be at that school.
And there is
resentment that builds.
How are you supposed
to think about that?
How does the country
think about that?
It is very difficult
for us to understand
that the numbers
of black kids going
to these elite
institutions is very small.
And 10 extra or
20 extra kids that
get inserted into
that freshman class
even if they didn't
have the test score
is not-- the effect it has on
the number of white students
applying and their chances
of getting in is minuscule.
But it feels big, because we
all know of a black kid who
gets in with a lower score.
It's this problem of using
the score to define deserving.
Anyone in this room and
listening and online and all
of that who thinks that
college admissions is
an objective process is wrong.
It's completely subjective.
The dean of admissions
says, we need a violinist.
Let's try and find a great
violinist for our orchestra.
This year, we need
more kids who want
to major in our new
curriculum in communications.
It's just about
building a class.
But we're so competitive.
And we compete against our
friends, and our kids' friends,
and our parents' friends,
all of this stuff,
that we end up resenting
the black kid who
got in with the lower score.
It's a big problem.
And I don't know how
to articulate it more.
LANI GUINIER: But I think
you've articulated it
very effectively.
The question is, what's
the intervention?
DEBORAH BIAL: How do we
change our mindset, almost?
LANI GUINIER: Well,
I think we have
to go back to understanding
what's the purpose of higher
education.
And it's not there simply to
give your child or my child
an opportunity to
make a lot of money.
It's also a very important
engine of democracy.
And that the part of the
college that we don't really
talk about-- that
we want students
who are going to
graduate from college
and make a contribution
to our society that
promotes democracy.
And by democracy,
I mean fairness.
I mean engagement
of the citizenry
in making decisions that affect
their lives and our lives.
College is not just a platform
for becoming a millionaire
or continuing in your
parents' footsteps
and being a person from--
DEBORAH BIAL: A great,
great way of framing it.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Are you OK
with somewhat more
of a comment than a question?
DEBORAH BIAL: Absolutely not.
You need to sit down.
No, just kidding.
AUDIENCE: I see
the essence of what
you're saying as three areas.
One is scoring people based on
some perceived ability being
done badly, and the alternative
is over-credentialism.
You have a degree.
Therefore, you must be qualified
to do an entire class of work
unrelated to the degree.
There is the diversity
aspect, where you're clearly
losing the game if
you're not getting
included in the solution.
And someone else is
disproportionately
winning the game.
But my pet peeve is the posse
versus singular model of it.
Survival of the
fittest is universally
accepted as the
driver of evolution.
If you have someone who keeps
his tribe alive by sacrificing
himself or herself,
then that person's genes
aren't being carried
down directly.
And therefore, clearly,
that person was a failure.
But if you look at how
evolution actually works,
the tribes succeeds,
the tribe survives
because one person was
willing to sacrifice
for the group's success.
And that strikes me
as an almost direct--
DEBORAH BIAL: Conflict of--
AUDIENCE: It's very
much the issue of you
have five people who are very
good each at one science,
and none of them can get along.
You add a sixth person who gets
people along with each other,
and finally, the team can
succeed rather than being
a bunch of individuals.
Even for leadership, which
is one of the aspects
we consider in recruitment,
it is hierarchical sort
of leadership we look at.
It is not management of a group
to make the group effective.
It is domination of
the group in order
to make the group
do what it's told.
And I feel like that is not
just some people are winning
and other people are losing.
But our consensus
as a society seems
to be on the wrong rules
of physics, you might say,
about how these things work.
And I feel like that is
an understanding that
needs to be spread, and
I'm glad you're doing it.
LANI GUINIER: Well,
I'm glad you just came
up and made what I thought
was a very powerful argument.
So thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I have just
enough personal experience--
not nearly as much as
either or both of yours
to be dangerous in
this-- meaning I
have a daughter who went
through the process this year.
And I'm a regional enrollment
director for my alma mater.
So I see a lot of really
scary numbers and experiences
happen, from both the applicant
perspective and the alumni
perspective.
So my view is the entire
process of getting into colleges
and going through college
is a completely broken
for everybody,
regardless of what
your socioeconomic,
racial, gender class is.
It's 100% broken for everybody.
And somebody has to do
something drastic soon
to take a leadership
role in changing it.
But because institutions
exist to continue to exist,
it's happening way too slowly.
So I'm going to tell you an
idea I sent to our admissions
director at our campus
this spring that I think
after his eyes and
ears got done bleeding
after he read the idea, he sent
me a politically correct note
back.
But my idea was-- because
all these colleges
are keeping score.
DEBORAH BIAL: Yeah.
The rankings and--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, rankings,
number of applications, yields.
There's all kinds of scorecards.
I said, my recommendation
is next year
we have no applications.
There is no application process.
The process is--
DEBORAH BIAL: Random enrollment.
AUDIENCE: Well, not exactly.
You take your
admissions officers
who spend time reading
too many applications
and delivering on the
admission director's
need for the communications
class or the violinist,
and they just go out
into the community,
and they find the right
1,200 people for you.
Why don't we do that?
Someone has got to be first.
And so my question
for you is, is
anybody close to being
first with anything
that matters in this?
The closest thing I
see to this is maybe
what's happening in technology
with EdX and things like that.
But they are still
premium institutions,
and they haven't figured
out how to commercialize it.
But is anybody doing anything
material to be first at this
and start to change it?
DEBORAH BIAL: I
have some things.
I love what you're
saying, because you're
saying we have to be radical.
It's not enough, this
little small-- Lani,
who is a civil rights expert and
witnessed the progress we made
is also witnessing,
as we all are,
how we are moving backwards.
We strike down the
Voting Rights Act.
And we lose affirmative action.
And we think--
because we're there.
We've solved the problem.
We have a black president.
Done.
But we need to be more
radical, because we move away
too slowly, as you're saying.
So MOOCs have evolved.
Higher ed is going to change.
We call it sometimes
the higher ed bubble.
Remember, we had these
other technology bubbles.
But it's going to burst.
People will not
be able to afford
this kind of higher
education within the next
I don't know how many years.
The schools can't afford it.
We can't afford it.
Something is going to change.
I just wanted to
mention-- this is not
supposed to be about Posse--
I wanted to mention that
this year, we had
15,000 nominations
from all over the United
States for 700 slots.
And every one of
those 15,000 kids
came from someone who
said, this is a great kid.
He should be going
to this great school.
Someone who believes in
this kid and knows this kid.
Frankly, in my opinion,
all 15,000 of those kids
should be sent to
these great schools.
Nothing would happen that's bad.
It would only be good.
But those 15,000
kids came into a room
that was radically different.
It wasn't about scores
and grades and tests.
It was about all of
these other qualities
that we think could
make a great student
on a campus and a great
leader in the workforce.
If we could do more of that--
replicate these large group
interviews, these large group
opportunities for companies
like Google to hire, for
schools like Vanderbilt
to admit students-- for whatever
it is that we're looking for,
it gives us another way
of finding talent that's
more radical, because it's
not just sitting in a room
and looking at a piece of
paper and making a decision.
I know we're
running out of time,
because we have three minutes.
But I love that.
And there are things
that are happening,
and I just think we
need to keep pushing it
really loudly, that we should
radically change the system,
or it'll just break,
like you said,
and then we will have no choice.
LANI GUINIER: We cannot
end on that note.
DEBORAH BIAL: No.
LANI GUINIER: So
please ask a question.
AUDIENCE: I'll be real
fast because of time.
Meritocracy rests on
a bedrock of scarcity.
We can only enlist x many people
each year, so how do we pick?
And you make good points
about changing the metric,
but you also mentioned
if I change the metric,
then some other people who
might have otherwise deserved
don't get to go.
The other way to
approach that problem
is to drastically
increase the number
of people who are able to go.
So what are your
thoughts about changing
that restriction of the
small number of people
who are able to go to college?
DEBORAH BIAL: That's positive.
LANI GUINIER: Yeah,
I agree with you.
DEBORAH BIAL: MOOCs might
be able to make that happen.
We may be able to create more
systems that take more kids.
LANI GUINIER: Or go to
Canada and see what they do.
DEBORAH BIAL: Canada again.
LANI GUINIER:
Because if you have
an 80% or above in terms
of your high school grades,
you're entitled to go
to college in Canada.
They've figured that out.
AUDIENCE: Right.
My kids are not Canadian.
I have a nine-year-old
and a six-year-old.
LANI GUINIER: A nine-year-old
and a six-year-old?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I've done the math.
LANI GUINIER: I'm glad
they're not getting
into college at this age.
AUDIENCE: Well, but I
have to start financially
planning for that now, because
it's going to cost me half
a million dollars to send them.
And how do we
solve that problem?
That's part of what I'm saying.
Literacy is so important that
we give it away for free.
LANI GUINIER: That's why
I'm saying go to Canada.
DEBORAH BIAL: I
think you're hearing
is that it's not an
answerable question right now.
You're right.
We need everybody to
feel like the opportunity
to reach an American dream,
whatever that dream is, exists.
And it feels
unbelievably unfair.
We're living in a
country that has
33% of its population
living in poverty,
or what we call
near poverty-- 33%.
Those kids, we don't
even talk about them.
Do you read about
the poverty that
exists in the United States?
You don't, really.
And so we need to talk about it.
The middle class has gotten
squeezed out of education,
because the cost is so enormous.
So we end up with schools that
we call rich-poor schools.
The rich kids can go,
and the really poor kids
can get these scholarships.
It's not enough.
And we need to find a way
to make state systems work
for everybody, to make
great schools expand
what they offer to more people.
We haven't figured it out.
You're right-- we
have to figure it out.
And maybe by the time
your kids are older,
there will be something great.
LANI GUINIER: But
it's not just--
I think what you
just said was great.
DEBORAH BIAL: It's too negative?
LANI GUINIER: No, no.
But it's something that--
we don't have the capacity
to solve that problem alone,
but it's an issue that--
that's why I keep
talking about Canada,
or you should go to Finland or
to other countries and see that
in these other countries, they
are committed to making sure
every student--
DEBORAH BIAL: To
use them as models
for something we could copy.
LANI GUINIER: Right.
If we think we are in a
position of greatness,
we need to go and actually see
greatness that is democratic
as opposed to plutocratic,
which is what we have here.
AUDIENCE: So we said
that test scores are not
predictive of college success,
but you have this Posse
selection process.
Is that predictive?
DEBORAH BIAL: Yeah.
So I didn't say
they're not predictive.
Test scores--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you did.
DEBORAH BIAL: Yeah,
they're limited.
They predict for some kids.
And the only thing
the SATs predict
is how well you're going to
do your first year in college,
what your GPA will be.
Again, it's like Lani said.
It's incredibly flawed, but
it finds some great kids.
Posse kids graduate
at rates of over 90%
from 52 colleges
and universities
that we send them to.
Thousands of Posse kids
have won $800 million
in scholarships over
the past 25 years.
So we've got a program
that's showing that what Lani
is talking about totally works.
We've got thousands of
kids in an experiment,
and this other way
of identifying talent
is just as good as the SAT.
All I'm saying is we can't
just only use the SAT.
We need many more ways
of finding great kids.
And then the cost
is another issue.
OK.
You guys, thank you so much.
Lani, a pleasure to be with you.
Thank you, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]